[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I found some food looks really good
- good good good
trying to focus mm-hmm well don't my dad
said to me just before I got me there
because it wasn't that obvious too busy
obsessing am a gamma ray experiment
finished my father's death because I was
focusing on my destiny but I didn't miss
my father's death because he was
murdered right in front of me by my
sister whom I didn't even know existed
because she was kept a secret from me my
whole life look terrible comparison
nothing to do with what you're going
through and my family it's like would
cost to fight amongst ourselves while
everyone else suffers for it no I was
gods and runes and well this is sister
hello I don't even know if I found Vita
you're for you could kill your sister
thought without his helmet you're not
the guy to hammers here Dumbo doesn't
sound like a compliment it's totally a
compliment Dumbo Dumbo this sounds like
you're calling me Dumbo over and over
again
Dumbo say once more not a herd of
elephants who think she can fly because
he's a magical feather and then he loses
his feather one day and he realizes
didn't have anything to do with him
flying at all was it sorry to him
[ __ ] feather man what I come from was
that me the whole time you think oh this
tail even same thing we're here yeah
yeah get rid of it
let's stop there you know what I woke up
this morning thinking about a public
execution I did I really did but for now
I'll settle for this you know sweet
little you know who's gonna get in first
so uh well you're on the clock
this means go did you not get that
that's the universal sign it was I not
clear
heaven's sakes what do you make of that
there's so many universal symbols this
is one that's obviously not communicable
what's this
dyed it down
that's dial it down what's this it out
no smaller okay here like deserters
here's I'd like dessert mmm that would
be us at specific this would be I won't
do this anymore
hey the boat not pay the bill this would
be that would be pay the bill this is
where's my check where's my check please
my cheek well it's such a such a great
great
[Music]
oh she's there everywhere um yeah I see
you've been familiarizing yourself with
our our obedience disk it's a little
invention of mine by the way
you know some people find it kind of
erotic walk with me I'm gonna tell you
something obedience disk I've never been
crazy about that name
that's supposed to be a placeholder
until I can think of something better
but everybody start to call them
obedience I didn't hear anything but
weren't those like sparkles out of your
fingers like lightning may be really
located your cousin oh good yeah there
he is hey cuz we always couldn't find
you what he been hiding hi hmm so got to
admit what you did Carlo what you said
it was only a small camels why did you
do it as small camels sampling gambling
I don't know what that means gambling
with the camel camping you said it was
camping knows about the cappings bad but
what you really do I was gambling that
blings Oh
gambling huh hmm Carlo I pardon you they
do it again though right officially
officially pardoned
from life
[Music]
a man with an iron hand Marvel Studios
hello my name is Taika Waititi director
actor
welcome to thor ragnarok Tychus humor
it's so particular and unique and quirky
all of these tiny little things hanging
washing on electrical cables that's
exactly what we do on it I'm into the
story a day on the set working with tyka
involves hijinks dancing day is just a
big kid we like that the whole time
carnage is cracking up on Steph Steph
later the most light-hearted fun set
I've been on Oh
scrapper 142 to 114 tooth scrapper look
at this worlds of amazement here through
this door top Australia
[Music]
as a Korean RadioShack carryin Walkman
the Korean iPod the Korean Plumbing
Supplies justly like earth Plumbing
Supplies
[Music]
that is how you make movies Korg played
by Taika Waititi is incredible answer
it's not funny because I'd kept saying
on play someone in this film you know
yeah gonna play good luck today we
believe that you can do it
this character is extremely fascinating
to me he's a giant man made of rock
stone and granite and opal but who knows
what's beyond that as a flesh-and-blood
my name is ty kytc I am the director of
thor ragnarok ultimately this film is
about thor ragnarok and his journey
she'll do some outerspace places people
often asked me why did you become a
filmmaker well the main reason just
wanted impressed my mum and dad and to
show them I'm not a loser
I get what you stay I can achieve some
dreams not my own dreams but other
people's dreams I can get close to being
JJ Abrams I know you wanted him as a son
but you've got me
I'm sorry I'm not JJ Abrams they say I
wish we called you JJ Abrams would have
been so much cooler you died on Star
Wars well it didn't alright mom and dad
I didn't you're stuck with me okay now
down to the nitty-gritty why did I make
this film for a kudos and followers on
Twitter what I really wanted to do with
Thor was capture the essence of Peter
Pan with a little bit of Terminator 2
a dash of independence day a smidgen of
on Golden Pond with a kind of tone of
beaches mixed in with my fair lady so I
think we've achieved that at the end of
the day we're all said and done the
films about two monsters some explosions
pretty ladies heads
men there's a Hulk then it's the credits
I did all the names of the people who
made it that's what we tried to do I
think we did it that's what I wanted to
achieve with this film or respect from
Taika Waititi from New Zealand
[Music]
to have this villain s be introduced in
such a strong way is really exciting
[Music]
I've had incredible fun playing with her
because I think her capabilities are so
surprising and so unusual she's not
simply sinister actually as somebody
who's played the villain in these films
I understand the responsibilities that
she has a huge presence which she can
express physically or verbally she just
has this off-kilter movement to her
character I was completely blindsided by
some of the happiest times have been
beating people up I think good
everything is different and new and
fresh and what drew my interest was
knowing that Chris was gonna be in the
film obviously not just because he's
attractive huge he's cute cute he's cute
his Christmas fun to be around he's a
funny guy I've never met a more generous
performer than Chris is incredible to
work with he holds this the whole
behemoth together like a lot of us a
riding on his shoulders and what
shoulders they are he destroys the idea
of what audiences expect from him as an
actor
it's just been this magical thing that
occurred this kind of really risky idea
bringing this whole world to life and I
think with Thor yet Hemsworth in front
and there was this very kind of little
sci-fi version of a Marvel picture
Canadian film he has grown a great
affection for Earth and humans and the
first time we saw him when he was
arrogant that can be this great kind of
strength and knowledge and power with
him but there's also a sort of naive
kind of kid there at the center of it
it's nice to have that contrast and that
mix biggest concern is that their
well-being of this world and he very
much is sort of looking out further into
the universe to make sure that threat
doesn't consume this world as well
you
[Music]
[Applause]
shut
please I'm your host big round of
applause for all of our undercard
competitors soon today died so recently
that's for what if show what a night
this is what you've come for
[Applause]
it's main event
making his first appearance looks quite
promising got a couple of tricks up his
sleeve
say no more see what you think plays
gentlemen I give you Lord of thunder
[Applause]
[Applause]
watch out French fingers they make
sparks okay listen
that's good ready to welcome this guy
here he comes
[Applause]
well there's nothing like
special connection with him
[Music]
is the defendant
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I have to get off this planet hey hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey we know each other friends were
[Applause]
dead there's so much has happened since
I last saw you
lost my hammer like yesterday sir that's
absolutely fresh Loki Loki's alive we
believe in his eye he's up there
Oh banner I never thought I would say
this but I I'm happy to see you hey vana
no burner only Hawk
[Music]
[Music]
this is crazy I don't wanna hood
here we go here we go you can't defeat
me Joey
after you
for is back and you cut your hair looks
good on you how do you think you to you
I want to get a closer look at this
fused with intergalactic extras that'll
blow your Wow
amen my name is cool what's this guy
again till we get C's Jack real
and an exclusive short team Darryl no
the Grandmaster was the only one who
answered my Craigslist ad yeah one two
three or the most fun you'll ever have
at a Marvel movie
Marvel's Thor Ragnarok
[Music]